今日は皆さん
よくこのチャンネルで私がいろんな
その言葉を使って日 d を作ります
まあ主に英語英語
で dd をつくってその言葉の勉強についていろんな話をするわけなんですよ
しかし最近はねその英語の勉強に関するビデオを作ろうと思っています
一番こえー行英語を勉強している人たちの一番さん
問題というか
acer no
いつも間違っていこう
英語を使っているその例よね
取り上げて簡単にそれについて説明したいと思います今日は
あのー
アイエヌジーのついている
うそ
んですか単語についてちょっと私の池もの待ちたいと思います
なぜですかなぜ橇は目
f 掴み構えですねこう
僕号がスペイン語の方と話しした時に彼女は愛煙母音ということを出しに言いました
im ボウリングというのははたちがつまらないですという意味なんですよ
たぶん彼女はそのああああ
m 防衛と言いたかったと思うんですよ
その間所は何かやっていることでそのこと自体がつまらないでやって彼女自身がそのつ
払い人間だという意味じゃないと思います
よくきっ子へますよね例えば聞かれます例えば
im インプレスティ私が非常に面白いですと所持そうじゃないでしょ
私が何何に対して興味ありますという意味なんですよ
imx it をにが非常にその方法
可能人に対してヒジェ刺激や耐える人だと化粧じゃないでしょ
アイアンエクサイズ一応にそのなんですかこの映画に関して非常にいまー刺激している
以上にもう楽しみにしているという意味なんですよ
だから
じゃこのエキサイティングか xi とぅ
インプレス tinker インプレスでボーリンガーボーイ
どちらローズ買うどちらをず買おうかというその説明はねいくらでもあります
それはその
文法の音調べればいろんなその説明もあると思うんですけれども
私はいろんな言葉を勉強して
その
はたちの座の何ですか経験からするとやはりそういう説明だけではですね
この問題を解決されないんですなぜかと言うと言葉の勉強というのは一つのなれなん
ですよ
新しい秀丸をつけないといけないでその説明は場合によっては約2
2つ場合によっては全然役に立たない場合によっては我々もわからないし
でしかしたが9さんそのんあるて r がのある決まったその
フリーズが何回も何回も観た中で経験したことで時々その間違って使ったりしたことの
上でその寸法の説明を読めばある程度ある程度
もう
そのやめたんですけれどもそれよりもやはりその
そのフェーズの使い方をそのくる自分で注意しないといけない
注意するためにですね
ぽるどへ i am ende アポロ aki そしてまた
go
何ですかレビューしてそれからまた
でいい面白い人ですねう我々あの場合によってはその全然キーナーキーがつかないよう
な
一派のその現象があるわけですけどもいっかい気がついてないですねその同じ現象は
いろんなところでその
注目できるわけですよそういうそれと同じ
その
意味でやはり臨機でそれをその
please を
保存したり読むときにそれはダライしたり
それからまた同じパターンですねどこかで聞いたときに注意してすることによってです
ね
新しい習慣をその自分のその何ですか頭
角にその
cg をするわけですよあそしてそれじゃああーぬーんですよ
なぜかというと週間あまりついてないですよだからたくさん読んだり
たくさんきっぱりそしてあの
アイアンボーイングアイエムプレスあの i read
marimori res demodee エージェントラスティング
でムービー exide ずボーリング dt チャーリーズ4 a steez
ディフューザーボーイング
imore arrest nomen 大アーチんがぁれ神そういうパターン21
にょぷらしいパターンがーアーマーの
中にも
あの何ですか
ポー着するわけですよしその決着するというかそれに基づいて少しずつ改善する可能性
がでん
言葉の勉強というのはあくまでもう慣れですよね
で今今日の話はでそれ同じその内容のビデオも英語でも先日あの
このチャンネルでやりましたからそれも見て
凛子使ってあればそれはうちのあの
ブラウザー駅選手んでもう速
林機に導入してちょっと読んだり聞いたりまたエビ3プレイヤーで聞いたり場合によっ
てはガチのビデオ見たりそれにんまずさの注意してそしてそれが一つで英語でですね
これは日本人はであろうがスペイン人であろうが何人でやろうが
だいたい伊佐の一番その a
普遍的なその
失敗というか間違えてるな常に今日ツールが多いんですよ
だからひとつずつひとつずつ注意して
それからたくさん読んだり引いたりするとエッ時々
説明まぁ興味あれば ap はインターレースとぅ
説明見てもいいんですけれどもそれよりも
少しずつ
慣れてくればだんだんそういうミスが少なくなってくるというわけなんですよ
今日はあのどうもみなさんよく
a 3
ime sinonome 草委員の話について聞いていただいてどうもありがとう
ございました
それじゃまたね